hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled keynote presentation
profiling of receptor complexes using
brett this webinar is part of the fifth
annual drug discovery and development
virtual conference and i'm susie valdez
of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find this live chat
located at the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window
below the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain those credits i
now present today's speaker professor
kevin fleiger the director of biomedical
innovation at the university of western
australia and the head of molecular
endocrinology and pharmacology at the
harry perkins institute of medical
research for a complete biography of all
of our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the left of your screen
professor flaker welcome you may now
begin your presentation
thank you very much and it's wonderful
to be here and thank you very much for
the invitation so i'd like to take you
today on a whistle stop tour of brett
which is bioluminescence resin's
anti-transfer and how we use that to
profile receptor complexes
so brett is a technology that is become
quite widespread now particularly in the
study of g-protein-coupled receptors but
also other receptor complexes
and we have our receptor of interest
which is conjugated to a luciferase
enzyme from
rhino luciferase particularly and we
also have an interacting protein
typically which is conjugated to a
fluorophore so that could be venous for
example
when you have a ligand binding to this
receptor in this example
you have the interacting protein come
proximal to that receptor you then have
proximity between the luciferase and the
fluorophore as a consequence you have
this resonance energy transfer and that
then results in light emission from the
acceptor which gives us an indication of
proximity
we use
standard fusion proteins cdna and
genetic engineering to remove the stop
codon and then have our
donor or acceptor constructs on the end
of our proteins of interest
we then transfect those into cells
either stably or transiently and then
put them into microplates and read them
on a typical instrument
we always
measure wavelength windows so we have
the short wavelength emission and the
long wavelength emission and these
depend on the different type of brett
that you use typically people use brett
1 with a yellow threshold protein such
as venus
so they are interested in the
long
interacting window here
over the short interacting window here
and then they subtract off the
background and that background could be
a parallel well of cells which has just
a donor present or typically we use a
a ligand-induced breadth ratio in which
case we have our
control which is just the vehicle
control so we have our ligand added to
one well
we then have this ratio and then we
subtract off the um
the well that has just the vehicle added
now bret 2
similar principle but
this has greater separation between the
two wavelength windows but with bret2 we
tend to have a much smaller emission so
that results in in lower sensitivity of
those
systems typically although they can
still be used particularly for
intramolecular brett systems
and you can use egfp you just have to be
very very careful about separating those
wavelengths windows
more recently
the nanobrett system has come through
and this enables actually transfer of
energy across to some very
red
shifted acceptors
and the advantage of this is that you
have much less
background here so if this is the
emission from the nanoluke here then we
have um
the different fluorophores and you can
see that if your fluorophore is actually
quite
close in terms of the spectrum you get
good energy transfer but there's more
background and then as you go further
away so these are more red shifted we
get
lower energy transfer but
less background so if you go into the
redshift where you're peaking at about
630 you have very little background from
your
emission from the donor so that's very
useful
so what i'd like to do is take you
through today
various different aspects so starting
with brett's receptor ligand binding
assays
then talking about how we monitor
receptor signaling and regulation
going through trafficking particularly
looking at cellular localization markers
using the brett receptor hit which is
the hetroma identification technology or
investigation technology
using that to look at heterogeneization
and then looking more
at the endogenous protein level using
the crispr cas9 system to bret tag
endogenous proteins
so the brett receptor ligand binding
assays to start with
this is the concept that you actually
attach
your
your donor your nanoluke in this case to
the n-terminus of the receptor and the
brett event actually happens across to
the thoroughfare which is attached to
the ligand and then you compete that off
with unlabeled ligand to give
competition assay
you can see here that you can do this
with a green
body
attached here to propranolol
and you can do do so also with red and
as i mentioned before the advantage of
red is that you get this much lower
background you can see here this starts
at zero whereas this scale starts at 0.1
and if you actually compare with
the scales starting at zero for both of
these you can see a much higher
background with the green
but we still get the same pharmacology
so the take home is you can use a whole
range of fluorophores of different
colors but the more red shifted the less
background
there's some illustrations of
these assays here and you can see this
this saturation here which has
many orders of magnitude and this is
very very uh useful
aspect of the luminescence technology
because we are using light we don't have
to worry about radioactivity so if
you're doing this with a traditional
radioactive assay this would be a very
very high level of radiation you just
wouldn't be allowed to do it so we can
get manuals of magnitude here because
we're using a luminescence-based
technology
the other advantage of using brett is
the real time aspect and we can actually
do these experiments in real time and
look at this in terms of kinetic assays
and actually see similar kds regardless
of whether we use this kinetic profile
or this saturation assay
we can also do this work with
peptides as well as small molecules and
you can see this is a timbra tamra
conjugated angiotensin ii
ligand and competing off with a range of
antagonists and agonists
so that's binding so moving on to
receptor signaling and regulation
we have arresting so a lot of people
have done work with
brett using arresting and this just
illustrates some of the different
profiles and again illustrates why it's
really nice to use real-time assays with
the brett because this is a wild type
laser press interceptor v2r and you can
see with some point mutations you get
some quite striking differences in the
kinetic profiles
comparing this one here to quite a
different kinetic profile so we can see
a lot of nuance with the brett system
because of the real-time aspects but of
course we can still do
some good old-fashioned pharmacology and
look at the concentration response goods
this illustrates the point here so this
is the erection system and if you're
just to measure initially both of these
receptors would look quite similar they
both come up to the same maximal breath
ratio however over time you can actually
differentiate between these two
receptors with the erection receptor two
having a much
longer and more prolonged interaction
between the receptor and the two
arrestings
illustrating the point again here we
have the g-protein assay so this is
using
an unlabeled receptor but we've anal n
luke's or nanoloop tag to the g alpha i
and then venus tagged the g gamma 2
subunit so we're looking at the
proximity of these or in fact the
dissociation of these two subunits and
we can see this as a ligand-induced
reduction in the breadth signal
ubixin is another
molecule that we can look at and see its
proximity to the receptor and other
molecules and here you can see in this
instance we haven't labeled the receptor
instead we've labeled the arresting with
the the luciferase and we've labeled
ubiquitin with venus and you can
actually see some quite interesting
profiles here which if you look at this
publication
you'll be able to see that we use this
to differentiate the two receptors
okay so that illustrates the various
different ways we can use brett to look
at proximity between the receptor
and regulatory and
signaling proteins now looking at
trafficking so this is work based on a
concept that nevin lambert's group came
up with which is that you can actually
label a fragment of k-ras that sits in
the membrane plasma membrane of the cell
and you can label various different rab
proteins and in particular they they
pioneered using wrap four five eleven
and some of these down here seven and
nine
so particularly looking at the the
uh internalization process
we also added and developed some some
markers looking at the forward
trafficking as well which we found very
interesting uh expanding that to things
like rav 1 rab6
and rab8 and actually looking at this
forward process
so this is all validated in this
publication molecular endocrinology
showing how these markers are labeled
with
venus are all in similar compartments to
the markers that you would expect to be
seen here so eea 1 and transfer in
lysotracker etc so this has all been
validated and it's a nice
assay because when you actually add the
likens to the receptor which is labeled
with luciferase you can actually monitor
that trafficking through the different
compartments away from the plasma
membrane and into the different
compartments in real
time so you can see some examples here
this is monitoring the vasopressin 2
receptor trafficking with brett you can
see it coming down away off the plasma
membrane so this is the coming away from
the k-ras so that the first panel up
there on the top left comes away from
the plasma membrane
and then traffics into the early
endosome
and then the fast recycling rap4
compartment and then over a longer time
scale through the wrap 11 slow recycling
compartment and then you've also got
traffic into the lysosome and the late
endosome through to the transcoding
network so you can actually see the
different compartments
as the
receptors trafficking through them
and on the other side you can actually
see some of the forward tracking which
is involved in the rav one going from
the imposing particular golgi the rab 8
going from the golgi up to plasma
membrane and the ram 6 going through the
golgi
apparatus
so
taking you forward in a slightly
different slant now this is looking more
at different complexes and
heterorization and looking at receptor
heat assays or the receptor hetero
investigation technology
so firstly let's define what we mean by
receptor heterogenization
and there was a group that came together
in bethesda uh back in the end of 2008
and then that work was published
although the the um the outcome of those
conversations were published in nature
chemical biology in this article here
and the group came up with this
definition so the definition is that a
receptor hetero is a macromolecular
complex composed of at least two
functional receptor units with
biochemical properties demonstrably
different from those its individual
components
so to pull that apart a little bit it's
a large complex involves multiple
molecules as we know these receptors
complex with a whole range of different
proteins they could be arrestings g
proteins various scaffolding molecules
so quite a large complex
there of course can be receptors and
there's a lot of debate about what the
the smallest receptor unit is
but um the concept here is a receptor
hetero
you have receptors in there that are
functioning their own right but when you
actually bring two receptors together or
more than two receptors
those receptors change each other's
function
so there's a change in the biochemical
properties from this
functional interaction so this isn't
just about proximity this is about a
change in pharmacology
so to illustrate here here we've got
potentially direct receptor interactions
but we could also have multiple receptor
interactions with other proteins are in
the membrane separating the receptors
that we're investigating
we could also have
a situation where we have adapter
proteins that are sitting
perhaps inside the cell which are
mediating these receptor interactions
and actually mediating the
um
the allosterism across the complex so
the receptors don't actually have to be
touching as long as allosterism can
occur across across the complex
so why is this important what are the
implications
well for a long time um we've done a lot
of screening in
systems where we look at receptors in
isolation
we might test a whole panel of receptors
a whole panel of compounds maybe
millions of compounds and we see a
certain effect
but of course in our cells in in
biology
it's more complicated than that
we have complexes of receptors that are
potentially interacting and potentially
functionally changing pharmacology so we
could have the effect that we would see
in our normal system our effect a as it
were
but we could also be seeing a
transactivation of receptor systems so
we could have effect b which is the
normal effect associated with a
gpcrb that it's interacting with or we
could have completely novel effects
which are specific to the receptor
complex
and this is important because we've gone
um over the last 20 years or so from a
situation where we've considered a gpcr
as
uh a gq coupled receptor for example and
it's particularly defined by a certain
g-protein-mediated pathway to this
understanding that we have bias and we
have the potential for multiple
g-protein pathways being activated we to
rest in scaffolding particular pathways
and and now that the field is now even
thinking about how these arrests and
scaffolds could actually be resulting in
further g-protein coupling inside the
cell so so the world is always changing
and we're always discovering new things
and this is all about the concept of
biased signaling
now to introduce um further complexity
is the concept that heteronomialization
and these complexes can actually result
in different couple of the g proteins
potentially different couplings of
restings and a different layer of
pharmacology so this is biosignaling but
it's also through heteromerization
now why is that important well this
could have ramifications for reducing
side effects
because it may be that
the reason some drugs have side effects
is that we have some unforeseen
transactivation of other gpcrs for
example
has a potential to increase selectivity
because if we understand the
pharmacology it's possible that we could
actually use that to increase
selectivity for example
a particular combination receptors may
be
expressed at certain levels in a certain
tissue which we're particularly trying
to target
the problem though is that understanding
this pharmacology is technically
demanding to assess
so what we've done is actually thought
about this and come up with a new
approach and this is called the receptor
hedge from investigation technology
it's quite a simple idea really but the
idea is that you have a first reporter
component on the end of one receptor of
interest
but instead instead of putting the
second reporting component
on the other gpcr of interest which is
what was traditionally done before
we actually label the
interacting group
and then the receptor when it's
activated the receptor b is activated by
a ligand
then the interaction group comes up
interacts with the gpcr complex and
brings the second reported component
into proximity of the first reported
component and as a consequence there's a
signal output
now this could be any proximity assay it
could be
brett it could be fret it could be um
the discovery system
and
enzyme fragment confrontation there's a
whole range of different uh potential uh
assay uh that could be used for this uh
that measure proximity
um and this is uh the example where
we're looking at this from the point of
view of an intra-sailor
interaction when we're looking at this
on panel on the left
panel on the right illustrates how you
can actually turn this up the other way
and use this to look at ligand binding
so this time we're actually looking at a
first reporter component labelled on the
n-terminus of the receptor
we then have our interacting group which
is actually a ligand and that is
attached to a fluorophore which is the
second interact the second reporter
component
the ligand then
competes off the interacting group and
therefore you reduce the brett signal
which is occurring between the first
reported component and the second
reported component on the breast on the
ligand
so this provides very nice composition
assay which is heteroselective
so
we've often in the past used luciferase
as the is the uh
the interacting uh group uh for the
first reported component
and then sorry the so luciferase is
often the first reported component of
the system
and then the interacting group in this
example is the resting and then the
second reported component is a yellow
fluorescent protein such as venus
this illustrates that um as you add the
ligand that is
selective for receptor b or the hetero
you have this complex here which gives
you your signal
however the other two complexes in this
rather simplistic figure are the ones
that are sitting in the dark because you
have a receptacle
that is not binding
ligand so it's not recruiting your
acceptor and therefore even though
luciferase is there we don't get an
energy transfer because there's no
acceptor
and over here we have receptor b that is
adding
that is a binding ligand but because
there's no donor there's again no brett
signal and therefore this complex is
also in the dark
so this gives us selectivity for the
hatchimal complex and that's the one
that gives you the readout
so to illustrate this
here we have the angiotensin
type 1 receptor
and the ccr2 chemokine receptor and this
is looking at the inhibition of the gl4i
activation because if you actually look
at the brett signal
you see activation of the geophy
by the chemical receptor
in the absence of the angiotensin
receptor
so you can see here you have a
concentration response curve as you
increase the the concentration of
chemokine
if you have a maximum dose of chemokine
as you add the angiotensin ligand
nothing happens because there's no
angiotensin receptor present
but interestingly
if angiotensin receptor is present is
present
the at1 receptor
you still get the same concentration
response curve as you increase chemokine
and interestingly if you have a maximum
dose of chemokine and then you add
increasing concentration of angiotensin
ligand and sensing two you actually
inhibit
the signal from the chemokine
so
we're actually seeing the angiotensin
receptor here
appearing to actually inhibit the
chemokine signal so that's a really
interesting piece of pharmacology
we've also seen this with the arresting
so here we have the chemokine receptor
interacting with the resting
and when we have the angiotensin
receptor present
when you add
angiotensin you get this small signal
here
as you add the chemokine you get this
signal here in blue but actually when
you add both angiotensin ii and the
chemokine
you actually see this more than additive
effect
so again interesting pharmacology
that you can see from this assay
and actually what this has done is led
us to the idea that you can actually
then
add
two antagonists to block both the
chemokine and the angiotensin signal
and it's only when you actually bad both
so you actually remove this signal down
to baseline
and this was the the forerunner that led
to some preclinical work and then is now
led on to work that so now actually in
multiple phase three trials one for
kidney disease and two for cobit 19.
so i'd love you to see this
this early stage drug discovery now
in phase 3 trials
and this is all work done by
now now being translated by the company
dimerics
so just to expand on this again this is
another combination to illustrate the
point we have the at1 angiotensin
receptor again but this time looking at
the receptor for advanced glycation end
products so this isn't gpcr this is a
different type of receptor
and
here you can actually see we've got our
receptor here that's our locate tagged
interacting with the resting you've got
a nice signal both for the angiotensin
receptor recruiting arresting and the
chemokine receptor ccr4
you can see that here
but with the rage
um that
actually only gives you this
receptor hit signal with the angiotensin
receptor the ccr4 does not give you the
same signal so this is a nice negative
control and showing this collective
proximity
and the edge tension
see
trafficking
um
again remembering that trafficking we're
looking at proximity of the receptor to
the plasma
risking through various different
and then also trafficking back up to the
membrane
this is interesting because
we tend to see the receptor coming away
from the membrane when it's activated
and so we would expect to see the signal
with k-ras go down
but in this situation it actually goes
up
so that's quite strange
and you would think it's even stranger
when you see the rab5 result because it
does seem to be going into the rab5
compartment so it comes away from the
membrane and goes into the rab5
compartment
and then if we look over here we see
rab11
so this is looking at the panel of um
of the the black and red dots
in panel e
so we're seeing across to the the far
right hand side we see in the rab 11
compartment
and that is actually indicating we're
going through the recycling in this open
compartment so if you see up on the
panel on the left hand side the the
receptor is going off the membrane into
the early endosome and then it's going
back through the recycling endosome and
back up to the membrane
now why this is particularly interesting
is because
well firstly why why are we getting an
increase in the receptor at the plasma
membrane when it seems to be actually
going into the cell
well the after that is looking at this
panel e where you see the rab eight
where that is actually actually that has
actually increased quite um quite a lot
and rab eight is where we're actually
getting trafficking from the trans golgi
network up to the plasma membrane
so if you look at that on the panel on
the left hand side
so in summary what is happening is even
though the receptor is being
internalized
and then recycle back through the
recycling endosome you're actually
getting an increase in forward
trafficking which means that the net
result is an increase of receptor on the
plasma membrane
we've also done uh work in other
receptor systems so not just tpcrs from
their friends but also receptorizing
kinases and this is illustrated here
looking at the proximity to grab two
and just to show you some pharmacology
here's some concentration response
curves looking at the egfr proximity to
her3 and this gives them again some nice
pharmacology
another illustration here um again a
receptors in kinase so this is a vegfr2
and a heterogenization with the b2
adrenergic receptor which is a gpcr
and you can see here that you have the
isoprene
giving you
the blue
kinetic and again this illustrates why
brett is very powerful giving you
kinetic data because you see the kinetic
with the iso
and as you then
add
the
the uh vegf165a
which is the open circles
so which is the um the red closed
circles that then gives you quite a
different kinetic
so if you can contrast the blue kinetic
with the red kinetic you see quite a
different profile and significant
difference there
whereas if you then add the
antagonist on top of that for vegf165
then you actually have
um
the kinetic that you just saw with the
iso in the first place so you reverse
the the change in the kinetic profile
that's resulting from the addition of
the vegf agonist
so hopefully that's clear but it shows
you very nicely that you can change the
kinetic profile and you can monitor
connect profile and again if you were
just to look at this after
say about 10 minutes
you'd be forgiven for thinking that the
response from these two uh was quite
similar but you need to see the k
profile to see the differentiation
and then it's quite striking
looking at the uh heterolyzation with uh
the b2ar here between the at1r
and the b2r this is actually looking at
the the ligand binding assay now
and
you can actually see we've got the n
loop on the in-terminus of the b-2-a
genetic receptor we're then having a
brett signal
energy transfer across the body labeled
propranolol
and then we compete off with unlabeled
propranolol and you see the saturation
curve there on the top right
now if you actually have the n-loop on
the
n-terminus of the angiotensin receptor
instead
then you actually have a brett going
across from that now luke across to the
body p labelled propranolol which is now
interacting with the b-2-agionary
receptor
which is now heterorising with the
angiotensin receptor
and again we can beat that off with
unlabeled propranolol
now the difference here
is you you still get a saturation assay
but you'll note
from the two
panels on the right hand side
the specific binding is about a tenth of
that
on the bottom panel compared to the top
panel because remembering that the
energy transfer is
is very dependent on distance
and in fact inversely proportional to
the distance to the sixth power so
you actually get a much lower breadth
signal because you're getting energy
transfer across the complex
okay and then in the final um
15 minutes or so i'd just like to take
you through uh the work we've done with
crispr cast nine and this has largely
been spearheaded by
my postdoctoral fellow carl white
who's now actually gone off to work with
dimerics which is fantastic
and he is he has really driven and
pioneered this um use of crispr cas9
for the brett system
so here we have the cxcr4
which is endogenous in a heck 293 cell
and this has been labeled with the
nanoluke on the c-terminus
so when you add your ligand
you've transfected these cells with
cxco4
and
you're sorry you've transfected these
cells with the
exogenous beta resting too low with
venus
but the cxcl4 is endogenous with this um
analogue attached with using crispr and
it's under endogenous promotion
so what that means is that when you're
doing your assays you're actually seeing
some some kinetics
which are
particular to that endogenous
protein
this is completed off by the antagonist
amd 3100
okay so then we can use this um to
actually do some quite nice screening
so we have a z-prime here where we have
endogenous protein uh tagged with the
bread donor using crispr
and this just illustrates that
the nanoluke is much brighter and
therefore
much more sensitive when you're using
very low expression levels
so here we have the z primes
with 0.66 if you've got 25 000 cells per
well
or 0.83 if you go up to 50 000 cells per
well and that's using a nano um
luke tagged beta resting two
and this is using exogenous v2r uh based
pressure receptor
labelled with venus
if you were to actually use the beta
rest in two labeled with alucate
and then use exogenous v2r venous you
have much lower z prime
because of the
the much
lower light output
as a consequence is much harder to
detect
we've used this process
to look at trafficking
so here we have the cxcr4
which is labeled again with an analog
using crispr
and then transecting in venus labelled
k-ras
as well as um
uh using the early endosome marker
wrap five for example
and you can see that
you can increase in the proximity to
around five as it traffics into your
enzyme and a decrease in proximity to k
you also get increased proximity to rab9
rab11 and wrap seven
now the other thing you can do
is actually
um oh let's come through there
the other thing you can do
is actually multiplex
so here you have the um the cxcr4 again
and luke tagged using crisper but this
time we've actually introduced
the k-ras with a halo tag which is red
and the rav4 which is venus labelled
which is yellow
so you can actually use an instrument
which can actually differentiate between
three different colors
and actually as a consequence
see
in in by multiplexing
the decrease
in the brett signal as the
receptor moves away from the plasma
membrane so reduction in the proximity
to k res halo tag and also
simultaneously
an increase in the proximity to rav4
venus
so that's very useful to be able to run
this
true multiplexing using the same well
so looking at receptor hit and this time
with endogenous cxcr4 again
um using the the analog tagged with
using crispr
here the exogenous gpcrs are transfected
in as well as exhaustion of beta resting
two venus
and
there's a couple of illustrations here
one is with cxcr4
um and the b2 adrenergic receptor
so both of these are classic examples
where
there's believed to be heteronomization
and you can see that you have the
chemical receptor
activated by cxcl12 giving you this
signal
you also have the iso giving you the
activation of the adrenergic receptor
again giving you this time of receptor
hit signal
but interestingly when you add both
ligands you get a much more additive
effect
so this is very much illustrating that
there is
some additional effect as a consequence
of heterolysation
this one is more complicated over here
on the on panel b
because you have
cxcr4 which is actually activated by
both
six seal 12 and 6 cell 11
but
cxcr7 is only activated by cxl11
so that means that if you activate
the complex with cxcl11
you just have this
quite small green signal which is the
activation cxcr7 across the complex
you then have
if you activate both
receptors
you'd have this
signal here in the blue which is
actually the same signal as the
activation with cxl12
because cxl12 activates both receptors
so whether you use both ligands or just
use cxl12 you get the same result
so to actually differentiate
this particular signal in red
there's no
cx cr7 present
so cxcl 12 just activating cxcr4
gives you the red signal so you can see
the addition of the red signal and and
the green signal here
is is much much
smaller than the actual additive effect
you get so again illustrating that you
have some kind of hetero effect here
in the last few minutes i just like to
touch on ligand binding
using the endogenous promotion system
so here we have
um in panel b
we have an illustration that if you're
transient transfecting in these
receptors so this is an in-luke tagged
adenosine
a2b receptor
and tagged on the n-terminus
that um if you put in five nanograms
which is actually quite a small amount
for a transient transfection you get a
very strong
luminescence the kind of luminescence
we're talking about with
crispr
when you've actually got the endogenous
receptor
is very very small so here you're just
looking at less than 6000
relative light units so to get that
similar level with a transient system
you'd need to go down to 0.05 nanograms
which is a tiny tiny amount of cdna
but you can see here
with normalized
soda camp accumulation they'll give you
similar um
slightly kmp
uh results so hector93 cells with
endogenous
atb and then these
transected cells and then the crispr atb
so even though you've got very very
little receptor there you can still get
some really nice saturation assays and
that's illustrated here and with very
nice clean flat um non-specific binding
this panel so that's panel b panel c
you've got a ligand there that is not
that is competing off with with um the
sch compound that is not selective for
the atv
um if you've used a huge amount of
hidden panel six the panel d sorry you
start to see a little bit of
non-specific binding
and panel e is illustrating that if you
you have a ligand fluorescent ligand for
the edge tension
then that is obviously not going to bind
and so you get no binding at all
and panel f just
illustrates that you can do this with an
agonist as well as an antagonist
now again with the brett system you can
do
really nice kinetic assays so you can
establish kds
using these kinetic experiments and also
of course do some nice um concentrated
response codes
and to illustrate the comparison
with um trends in transfection
compare this with the next slide where
you can see um you know an experiment
that we would normally do which happens
in transfection with five nanograms you
get nice clean data but
if you were to drop that amount to 0.05
nanograms you get very very noisy data
so if you compare
the crispr cells where you get this nice
clean data and some good concentrations
most curves
similar expression level with transient
transfection you get some quite messy
data and that's because the transient
transfection
you're not necessarily having the same
concentration of receptor in each cell
so with that i just like to acknowledge
all of the people that have done
the work um
over many years we've had great
collaborations as well
both academic and industry and of course
a huge amount of funding to do this work
so with that i'd like to open the floor
for questions thank you very much
thank you so much dr feiger for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in
our first question
what is it best to use nano bread
compared to brat one and when doesn't it
really matter
okay so um
as i showed there if you're using very
very low expression levels of protein
it's very good idea to use nano bread
because it's so much brighter
it's also good i could idea to use nano
bread if you're doing the combining
assays
when it doesn't really matter
necessarily if you've got
good expression levels and you're doing
something like an arresting receptive
proximity assay
then
then perhaps it doesn't matter so much
and also the trafficking assay
again that that's fine with allocate
venus in our hands but again um you just
have to
remember if you're going down to very
low expression levels then the nana
brett is probably your best bet on that
one
thank you so much and how does receptor
hit compared to brett saturation assays
okay so saturation assays have been used
in the field for a number of years um
and they give you an idea of the
proximity of two proteins in the
membrane so
the difference with the receptor hit is
that it tells you about the functional
interaction
so because you're adding ligand
and you're looking at a recruitment of
an interacting protein it gives you an
idea of the functional readout
and it also means you can use that for
screening for heteroselective compounds
as well which is not quite so easy with
the breadth saturation assays which
which are quite a lot of work because
you've got to get a lot of data points
um for each of those saturation curves
you can actually um
add ligand to those and generate
multiple saturation curves and sometimes
they shift depending on the presence of
ligand or not which can be useful um but
um
they're a lot more sort of laborious
experiments
thank you so much professor flager and
thank you to our audience members for
these questions coming in
our next question
um the audience member says hi kevin
great talk are you able to look at
residence time
of the receptors with each other the
ligand with receptors or the g protein
ariston with the receptors with brett
yes absolutely i mean um there's a lot
of work being done in
steve charles doing some nice work
residence time
um so you can you can you can generate
time constants um
with the brett system i mean that's
really where i think brett's system
lends itself to
um
to pharmacology because it can do this
real-time aspect so absolutely
thank you so much now do you have any
concerns professor veger about
brett giving signals due to over
expression
yes i mean i think this is an important
point
if you if you put enough protein into a
cell
you're going to get some kind of
bystander brett or or um
or at factual brett and that's that's
why the breadth saturation assays were
originally developed
to just illustrate that and why we use
receptor hit because that ligand
dependency
gives you that
that control but with all brett it's
good to have negative controls
it's good to include
particular combinations of proteins that
don't give you a signal that gives you
some confidence that um that you're not
looking at over expression artifacts um
the other point to make as well is with
the trafficking assay um because you're
using uh rabs and they they're they
express very well you're effectively um
putting a sort of a a mine field on that
membrane as it were
so you are utilizing that bystander
brett um so that actually
is useful in that respect but you just
have to realize that um that those
receptor those um
those interactions or the proximity
you're seeing with the bread is a
bystander signal largely
thank you so much and professor villager
we have one more question coming in from
our audience
which instrument do you use for the
brett
so we tend to use the claria star um
and the advantage of that is that
because it's got the linear variable
filter you can actually
um
you don't you're not set on sort of
specific wavelength windows and you can
actually do a lot of acid development
and that's what we tend to do
so um
and in particular you can use that for
looking at three different wavelength
windows
and i illustrated some
experiments there where you can actually
look at the the blue channel for the
luciferase the yellow channel for the
venus and the red channel for the head
attack
um and that's it's quite a good
instrument for that because you can
actually look at all three um channels
there's also high throughput instruments
like the the ferrostar
if you want to do really high throughput
then then that can go to that level as
well so um
so those are the two main instruments oh
the other one is the lumi style which is
um
sort of more
just for luminescence
and that can give you simultaneous
detection as well
um we tend to use the claristar
professor flager thank you so much for
your presentation today do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go
um well my main comment would be to say
if you're interested in using brett
please um please email me or or
send me a um
a note through linkedin um very happy to
to help you out um we have sent
constructs all over the world literally
all over the world
and very happy to help
help you get set up with brett i think
it's a fantastic technology
i think it's really opened up
pharmacology over the last um
20 years almost since i've been working
this field but um
but uh you know you've had people like
michelle brilliant being trailblazing
this as well and um
some great people doing some great work
around the world in it so i think um
i think it's a wonderful enabling
technology i think a lot of people using
it the first review i wrote on brett
back in 2003 i think it was
i managed to find less than 100 articles
on brett on pubmed and now if you tried
to do that you'd be finding thousands of
articles so
so that's quite uh
quite a transition over the last 20
years so um
absolutely
professor flagra thank you again for
your time today and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed for two years
until february 2024 on that on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone and bye
thank you